c'est avec accès mais bonjour axel
bonjour boris johnson et en inde depuis
hier et même à des milliers de
kilomètres de londres le premier
ministre britannique n'arrive pas à se
défaire du party game oui le scandale
des fêtes clandestines à downing street
pendant le confinement sanitaire
rejaillit sur sa visite en inde regarder
la une du guardian boris johnson posant
devant un templière alors que les
députés au même moment discuter de son
sort et le deuil aux féminines chaîne le
jour de l'humiliation titre le guardian
dans les députés ont ouvert une enquête
parlementaire pour savoir si boris
johnson les a trompés dans cette affaire
dans ce parti guette deux responsables
conservateurs l'ont de nouveau appelé à
démissionner après si je le gardais les
regarde a aussi cette caricature parue
dans la presse britannique on y voit à
boris johnson qui explique à si loin du
parti guette il est en forme de
représenter en charmeur de serpents en
l'occurrence c'est une corne et puis et
puis avec le parti ghad qui le rattrape
et cette corde qui devient une corde de
pendu voilà donc ce dessin à l'humour si
british publiée à ce matin par un
journal britannique est à la une de
l'actualité comme toujours depuis deux
mois la gare en ukraine oui est ce ce
reportage du figaro à la rencontre de la
communauté grecque d'odessa qui affiche
son soutien à l'ukraine comme un juste
retour de l'histoire avec la présence
notamment d'un consulat dans la vieille
cité portuaire un juste retour de
l'histoire pourquoi parce que c'est une
sorte de tribu mémorielle explique le
figaro captain paye à une ville qui a
joué un rôle important dans l'histoire
récente de la grèce et à la création
d'un état grec moderne c'est à odessa
que fut fondé une organisation secrète
qui a ourdi les plans de l'indépendance
grecque un vis-à-vis de l' empire
ottoman un témoin raconte au figaro que
les russes traite aujourd'hui la
population ukrainienne comme les
ottomans à traiter les grecs orthodoxes
s'apprête à fêter pâques dimanche mais
la guerre politis cette célébration
religieuse
en russie la hiérarchie orthodoxe
appelle à soutenir sans faille le
hamelin et son offensive militaire en
ukraine le patriarche kirill que vous
voyez ici en photo prototype d'un
faut-il le rappeler a appelé les fidèles
à se rallier pour combattre les ennemis
extérieurs et intérieurs toute la
hiérarchie de l'église continue le
correspondant à moscou de la croix toute
la hiérarchie de l'église orthodoxe a
multiplié les serments en faveur de
l'offensive saisissant l'occasion pour
prôner des valeurs conservatrices face à
un occident présenté comme décadent et
puis regardez ce dessin cette caricature
ce cartoon publié dans le telegraph
on y voit vous savez il a annoncé
vladimir poutine où vous le savez
peut-être pas mais je vous le rappelle
son inauguration de son entre guillemets
nouveau missile balistique
intercontinental et on le voit qui par
contre bâle et d'un réchaud et
d'ailleurs a bien fonctionné et d'hervé
arrêté de me menacer et on le voit avec
sur le nom de guerre de ce missile
s'attend d'eux est
représentée façon le ballon de baudruche
qui part dans tous les sens
vladimir poutine la mort de jacques
perrin à présent le comédien est
chevalier blanc de la production
indépendante oui ce titre assez le titre
de la nécrologie du monde marin rêveur
dans les demoiselles de rochefort prince
charmant dans peau d'âne le producteur
de microcosmos c'est surtout affirmé
comme un homme de cinéma engagé rappelle
le monde entier d'état jeudi hier à
paris il avait 91 ans et vous le voyez
ici dans son uniforme de l'académie des
beaux-arts a parlé de mike tyson
maintenant qui donc refait parler de lui
l'ancienne star de la boxe frappe un
homme qui le harcèle lors d'un vol c'est
une vidéo qui fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux et c'est le washington post par
exemple qui nous en parle vidéo où on
voit un homme qui énerve un franchement
tyson tyson est assis dans son fauteuil
en première classe l'homme l'énervent
terol dit d'arrêter et bam la bête se
réveille visage ensanglanté on voit
ensuite l'homme au british heart
déchirait aussi après la correction
infligée par iron mic est alors pour la
petite anecdote nous rappelle nous
explique le washington post ils
revenaient d'un festival hippie à san
francisco mytheon puisqu'il a fait
fortune refait fortune dans le business
légal du cannabis et c'est lors de ce
vol qu'il a eu cet incident avec un
passager plus j'en profite pour vous
montrer la seule une que je peux vous
montrer ce matin dans la presse
française qu'il faut battre il faut pas
parler au nom du campagne présidentielle
de campagne je vous montre ce décès dans
ses lecteurs un contexte électoral et
bien sûr la une de l'équipe kessé bah
voila quand y'a pas grand chose non plus
à dire dans le sport
d'attirer le lecteur avec opérations et
mbappé comment le qatar faire pour
garder l'attaquant star du paris saint
germain le qatar qui détient bien sûr le
psg merci pour cette seule presse axel